[Applause]
oh my gosh you're funny so I'm leading
with that have you met Jay before no I'm
I'm like sandwiched in between like two
American icons right now I love that I'm
somehow in the same sentence as him
thank you is that the old Mr Beef
restaurant it is that's what was that's
my favorite my picture is on the wall
your picture is on the wall that is the
most guy-centric restaurant there's not
a vegetable than a hundred miles no it's
just like a sausage rolled in Italian
beef in a roll they dipped the whole
thing in some kind of Grease yeah
fantastic fantastic my mouth just
watered and I'm not a dude I was like I
think it sounds awesome I heard that you
wanted to ask Jay something well I mean
it's sort of we could discuss it you
know I don't know if there's like a an
overt question oh I did I I got my
license so I got my license for the show
I'm from the east coast and so I would
really I grew up in Boston I know I'm
from Dorchester are you a double decker
Triple Decker Triple Decker
[Music]
yeah now those are all those are all the
cool houses yeah okay so you didn't
drive there I didn't drive there I just
took the tea and then I went to school
in New York and I was like I'm gonna I'm
gonna take the train forever I'm gonna
live forever
um and then I moved out here and I was
like what are we doing we're driving see
that's my nightmare forever that I
needed to have do you find you you like
it
when you drive
it's me imagining driving I like it I
like
putting on a song I've never driven yeah
playlist I like putting like a playlist
you know kind of like getting in a Zone
you'll get to know this is your alone
time yes I like alone yeah yeah yeah
don't get in the zone drive the car
okay don't go in a Zone okay so you
started out learning comedy in Boston
like Jay right
what was that like
um it was a lot of open mic nights and
um my friends and I we were kind of
interested it's like we got interested
pretty young and so it was like us in
high school like a bunch of weirdos who
did improv and were like we could try
this stand-up thing yes I think that's
so cool so that that very strange person
going to like an open Bike Night in
Boston where it's like all these you
know like dudes especially you want to
like grown people who are like let me
tell you about my wife and I'm like
but Boston's a great comedy town because
it's such a quirky Odd Place yeah I love
Boston it's just one of my favorite
touring stops oh here's here's I'm gonna
give you a Boston compliment I'm gonna a
guy this is a boy and you'll probably
agree this is about I'll try to use
different words guy says to me hey my
friend The Stranger come my friend met
you in California he said you're not an
yep oh I went oh well thanks the guy
goes no really I go well thank you very
much sir I appreciate that and that I
mean that's a compliment in Boston when
I am when the show came out my my
parents came to the premiere
um and my dad was like uh you know I
think I'll actually watch this one and I
was like
oh um thank you thanks Dad and he was
like no
no
it's very suspicious about what are you
in California now you got a gardener out
there or you do your own garden I do my
own garden oh okay there
sizing you you can't be putting on those
airs you know Triple Decker accredited
at all
that's a whole nother level well I want
to say congrats on the bear I mean so
much success so for those of you who
haven't seen it tell everybody what it's
about uh it is about a restaurant in
Chicago it's an Italian Beef restaurant
and uh it's the people who work there uh
when they get along when they don't and
yeah just trying to make it like a legit
Place yeah it's it's amazing it did so
well everybody was talking about it also
oh yeah it's a lot of fun and it's a
real play I yeah whenever I'm Chicago I
go there and your picture I've like I've
I looked at your picture while we were
filming it I'm like I'm like 19 in that
picture yeah and it looks all it's all
cleaned up oh there it is there you go
Mr beef thank God that's hilarious I
love the name of this place right you're
walking around I'm a little hungry you
know you're not crazy you're not getting
a veggie burger what are you doing Mr
Beef
vegetarian is going in yes it's like
stepping in a time capsule there too
like it's like their cash only so I
think like it's like everybody who's who
works there has worked there for forever
they're like all such a family I love
those kind of places yeah yeah it's
really cool well this is a good segue
um we will all be doing some cooking in
our next segment you look scared
I I got a heads up about the recipe
okay the bear is streaming now on Hulu
you've got to watch it
[Music]
[Applause]